here's what I really say about body
count The Testament of your body count
is more your rejection rate than how
many people you slept with let's take
somebody like you for example who's got
a big name on social media looks great
access to loads of women through the
nightclub now if your body count is
let's say if it's 10 but you've had
hundreds of girls throwing themselves at
you yours is actually still low whereas
if another guy who has no access to
women but finally gets one or two girls
to sleep with him on paper it might be
less but his rejection rate is so low so
really look at how many people your
partner is rejecting rather than just
their body count because on paper a
really unattractive man who has nothing
going for him his body counts going to
be low doesn't mean he's a decent man
it's just that he didn't have the
opportunity similarly women that are not
that nice to be around not that kind not
that pretty not that attractive hers is
going to be low doesn't mean she's
virtuous it's just that she didn't have
access it's the ones that have access
but choose to be selective that's what
you should be looking at is there
selectivity